[Música]
definitivamente nós vivemos num mundo de
informação excessiva não é nada fácil
estar sentado ali nessa poltrona diante
de 500 canais de televisão é uma
disponibilidade enorme de informação
apesar disso o sistema da terra eo meio
ambiente estão ocultos nesse ruído
informativo um processo que se chama
green wash da grande mídia não se ouvir
muito falar sobre a natureza ela se
houve apenas dizer que a o mundo lá fora
que parece estar em revanche
são catástrofes naturais seja por
fenômenos atmosféricos severos seja
também por desabamento de encostas como
esta em nova friburgo ou inundações
inundações em todas as cidades sejam
elas grandes sejam elas pequenas
nós podemos nos perguntar então é
natureza que está nos ameaçando ou será
que a nossa cultura que não considera
sua ação na natureza e nem da natureza
em nossos artefatos que quer de fato eu
estou falando isso falando de outra
coisa que também não se fala dela as
cidades as cidades que crescem por todos
os lados
assumem novas fisionomias cidades como
nunca vimos antes
imaginem cidades que escalavam montanhas
cidades que parecem falésias e mensagens
como estas que vocês estão vendo isso é
na china imagine ser síndico de um
desses edifícios em é problemas que não
faltam cidades que parecem placas
flutuantes em que as ruas mudam todos os
dias cidades muito complexas como e
simplificado aqui por essa imagem é que
é uma junção em espaguete
nós pensamos que a civilização e se
tivesse construída sobre rocha firme
firmemente ancorada
mas na verdade o
nos ameaça hoje imaginem são os céus os
gases
quero dizer à atmosfera jamais
imaginamos isso no século dos nossos
avós e dos nossos bisavós porque não
imaginávamos isto porque há ali uma
terra que não vimos essa terra somente
foi revelada quando da corrida espacial
pela polo 17 essa imagem que vocês vêem
é a primeira fotografia da terra total é
a imagem full year
ela é muito mais famosa que as imagens
de grandes modelos ou de grandes
jogadores de futebol como o neymar é a
imagem mais difundida e essa imagem e
toda a corrida espacial nos revelou que
o nosso céu quer dizer a nossa atmosfera
é uma tênia e deu cada camada muito
muito fina e ela assim podem ser
impactadas
mas há ali também em segredo em segredo
que se mostra pelo fato de que se
considerarmos a radiação recebida pelo
sol que deve ser igual à radiação
emitida da terra para fazer prevalecer a
lei da física a de não haver consumo de
energia a temperatura da terra deveria
ser de menos 18 graus centígrados e na
verdade ela é lésbica tudo se graus
centígrados positivos há portanto um
excesso de temperatura de 32 graus
esse é o nosso mistério e para entender
melhor nós temos que ver como funciona a
o balanço de energia é do calor que a
terra recebe do sol ela recebe 342 watts
por metro quadrado 168 são absorvidos
pela terra ela superfície outro algo rs
é absorvido pela atmosfera e 107 batição
é devolvido para o espaço
mas na verdade a superfície da terra
devolve uma 390 partes por metro
quadrado é dos quais uma parte devolvida
à atmosfera exatamente 342 barris
somando os números ali em cima e há aqui
um excesso
o excesso de 324 vagas por metros
quadrados não se preocupem isso não vai
cair na prova na é apenas para ilustrar
um pouco né
as complexidades dos mecanismos da
radiação solar é e efeito na desta sobra
de calor que faz com que haja na terra
água no estado sólido líquido gasoso
essencial para a vida e esse mistério é
então resolvido na pelos gases de efeito
estufa
são eles que produzem este calor de 32
graus fundamental para a vida e os
sistemas vivos da terra e quem são esses
gases de efeito estufa é o vapor d'água
o dióxido de carbono o metano o sono
óxido nitroso isso é natural
e dependendo da concentração desses
gases na atmosfera
junto com a radiação solar nós temos a
possibilidade de ter muitas mudanças
climáticas muitos tipos de atmosfera no
sistema terrestre
nós não temos marcas do tempo nesta
imagem nesta fotografia da terra mas
aqui nesta face dessa senhora dessa
mulher
nós vemos as marcas indeléveis do tempo
então eu preparei isso pra vocês
na a terra é uma senhora muito idosa ela
tem uma memória prodigiosa e ela em um
longo tempo de existência e assim também
a atmosfera da terra
vamos fazer um mergulho nessa história
vamos lá para 300 milhões de anos atrás
quando pela primeira vez os continentes
terrestres se vestiram de verde e essas
primeiras florestas da terra fizeram um
serviço fundamental para nós
elas retiraram gás carbônico da
atmosfera e acumularam ele em termos de
carbono é contido no carvão mineral
hoje quando nós queimamos esse carvão
estamos devolvendo para atmosfera um
processo que ocorreu há 300 milhões de
anos atrás
estamos de fato mexendo na memória muito
antiga dessa senhora idosa desta terra
mais recentemente do quaternário
atmosfera terrestre passou por muitas
transformações
essas informações dão conta de várias
cidades do gelo várias cidades gaúchas
glaciais não apenas uma e graças é esse
desenvolvimento
pude então uma espécie homo sapiens
sapiens se desenvolver e se distribuir
em muitos habitats da terra e hoje o
homo sapiens povoa quase todos os
habitats terrestres ea população não
parou de crescer
hoje nós somos 7 bilhões de habitantes
dos quais três pílulas 6 bilhões mais da
metade vivendo em cidades sim nós somos
uma espécie de safin sapiens urbs
eis aí a nossa diferença e todo esse
nosso gigantismo claro deixa o impacto
nos sistemas terrestres chamamos a esse
novo período da terra de antropoceno a
era em que a humanidade atingir por fim
uma capacidade de ação geológica
nós podemos medir esse impacto na
atmosfera esse impacto pode ser medido
pela concentração de gás carbônico longo
do tempo aqui está a curva de killing
que foi quem primeiro me pediu essa
concentração em 1958 e a partir dele
nós vemos que a concentração de gás
carbônico na atmosfera não pára de
crescer
hoje alcançamos 400 pms na o que é um
valor muito alto para o período do
luciano
outra maneira de sabermos da memória da
atmosfera sim é pelo gelo o gelo gravar
por finas bolhas que estão contidas nele
as atmosferas antigas e com base nisso
então nós podemos saber como foram as
atmosferas super recentes e até a
atmosfera as muito antigas como
atmosferas de 500 mil anos atrás
juntando todos esses dados nós podemos
agora construir curvas de variação da
temperatura ao longo do tempo essa curva
que vocês estão vendo mostra a variação
de temperatura desde 1850 até hoje
vejam como aumentou a temperatura já
alcançamos o primeiro grau centígrado de
temperatura nome ela quer dizer maior do
que aquela que era em 1850 a observem
esse gráfico nos últimos 37 anos bem à
direita a temperatura começou a sumir
mais vertiginosamente ainda quanto agora
nós olhamos a temperatura de todo o
oceano isto é de 11.500 anos atrás nós
vemos que lá por sete mil anos mais ou
menos no meio do gráfico ela atingiu seu
apogeu
mas recentemente bem à direita do
gráfico ela tomou o elevador e subiu
vertiginosamente fazendo com que hoje a
temperatura que temos ali ela seja
superior a qualquer temperatura a vida
nos últimos 11 mil e quinhentos anos
esta é a questão do aquecimento global
esta é a questão e nós temos que olhar
para pensar as mudanças climáticas que
estão aí quem produzisse aumento de
temperatura do antropoceno em ele sim o
grande vilão a emissão de gás carbônico
representado aqui em laranja pelos
combustíveis fósseis emitidos por carros
usinas termelétricas é atualmente nós
estamos emitindo 49 giga toneladas de
gás carbônico na atmosfera uma
gigatonelada é mais ou menos um cubo de
um quilômetro de lado na ação um bilhão
de toneladas e estão as 49 gigatoneladas
emitidas por ano
lembrem-se atmosfera muito tendo ela é
muito delgada isso é muito para a
atmosfera e isso então é aumenta a
temperatura é da superfície terrestre
nós temos três cenários possíveis para
este século
o primeiro cenário continuar emitindo
gás carbônico da forma que está no final
do século as temperaturas poderão
ultrapassar quatro graus centígrados se
nós diminuímos um pouco a temperatura
poderá alcançar 3 graus centígrados mas
se nós tomarmos decisões mais firmes
quem sabe nós possamos alcançar 2 graus
centígrados todos os modelos científicos
indicam que nós não devemos ultrapassar
dois graus centígrados porque há uma
imprecisão dos modelos a um aumento do
grau de incerteza sobre a nossa
capacidade de prever como se
desenvolverá esse futuro o que isso
implica isso implica na diminuição da
cruz fera diminuição da calota polar a
perda de hábitats na como está se
verificando no pólo norte ou também a
diminuição de terras à agricultura como
esta em bengala é onde se planta arroz
aumento de secas como aqui na austrália
o aumento de inundações como estamos
acostumados a ver hoje quase que
anualmente
temos um grande desafio pela frente é o
desafio da sustentabilidade da gestão
planetária do clima ora como nós vamos
fazer isso como eu posso participar
disso este é meu foco é esse meu centro
de atuação
mas para isso nós precisamos entender o
segundo grande terreno que é o
desenvolvimento de sittard gigantes nós
hoje somos uma rede de cidades que
capeão todos os continentes todos os
habitantes da terra - aqueles que são
altamente nós pilotos e essas redes de
cidades é tem cordilheiras urbanas
megalópoles como essa que vai de
washington disse
até é boston passando por nova york
neste eixo e 820 quilômetros vivem cerca
de 53 milhões de pessoas
aqui está uma megalópole na ásia para
falar apenas de uma essa megalópole
ganso cano sul num raio de 220
quilômetros abriga 130 milhões de
habitantes somos então uma uma
gigantesca rede de cidades fisicamente
ancoradas nos ecossistemas terrestres e
as cidades todos os dias demanda uma
grande quantidade de elementos para
sobreviver e ao mesmo tempo descartam
toneladas e toneladas de rejeitos algum
deles tóxicos
eu chamo este organismo que gere mal
aquilo que traz para as cidades de
morasse no ele tem primo o velo se no
hoital vim foi parece que a cidade tem
um ímpeto de serem velozes quem decidiu
isso a cidade sendo velozes nos deixa o
tempo para cuidar dos nossos jardins das
nossas praças cuidar das nossas ruas
cuidar de nós mesmos cuidado com esses
dois senhores na oração do velocino
porque eles determinam um na os rumos da
cidade
aí está o atlas do século 21 ele não é
igual ao atlas um deus semideus
carregando globo
mas ele é um ser humano frágil
vulnerável carregando as cidades nós
precisamos aliviar o peso da cidade
sobre os ombros humanos
este é o grande desafio de diminuir a
pegada ecológica
para tanto nós temos que resolver alguns
problemas o primeiro deles é a
representação das cidades nós não temos
hoje uma representação
disponível que ajude os cidadãos e
cidadãs a entenderem a complexidade do
mundo urbano eu chamo isso de um
paradoxo cognitivo o segundo para docs
punitivo é fato de que a cidade não é
apenas um objeto que está fora de nós
ela também habita nossa mente a cidade é
faz com que nós não enxergamos o
ambiente que está lá fora ela captura
nossa mente por inteiro e daí nós
podemos dizer que esse é o paradoxo da
cegueira para enfrentar esses paradoxos
nós temos que usar uma estratégia comum
essa estratégia deve ser embasada no
conhecimento na educação nos programas
de gestão social ambiental e climática e
também na participação cidadã em porto
alegre
eu desenvolvi um enorme atlas é o mais
moderno do mundo em 1998 ele foi lançado
e hoje ele foi repetido por mais de 60
cidades entre elas viena na áustria
parcelou na buenos aires são paulo lima
enfim um exemplo para o mundo este é o
conhecimento e com base nele nós podemos
implantar um novo sistema de educação
das escolas municipais
ele se chama laboratório de inteligência
do ambiente urbano esse laboratório de
inteligência ele é um laboratório em que
as crianças desenvolvem uma educação com
base no lugar é a construção dos saberes
para identidade local é entender a
escola como um importante centro de
saberes locais a escola se capacita
assim a ser um equipamento instrumento
aberto a sua comunidade transparente a
sua comunidade porque dentro dela os
alunos estudo investigam e entendem o
ambiente local eles produzem maquetes do
do relevo do bairro onde se situa a
escola eles desenvolvem mapoteca suma
potecas temáticas eles fazem mapas
geológicos eles fazem mapas de biótopos
eles fazem mapas é do crescimento urbano
do bairro eles também desenvolvem lito
teclas sim nós vamos com os alunos ao
campo visitamos o painel coletamos
amostras de rochas e levamos elas para a
escola e eles organizam a loteca e
conseguem contar vejam a história
geológica do bairro da cidade da região
onde eles
ora eles conseguem ainda fazer vários
eles fazem é históricos fotográficos e
todo esse material fica ali dentro da
escola como uma memória cognitiva como
um processo de construção do
conhecimento local em que geração após
geração eles podem ver o que os alunos
antigos estudarem e desafios que eles se
colocam para insultar hoje é um processo
formidável esse de ensino educação nós
implantando já 32 laboratórios em toda a
cidade de porto alegre e são quase 700
alunos por ano cerca de 60 professores e
se mobilizam em torno dessa proposta uma
proposta que se organizem rede cin
certos alunos de um bairro visita os
alunos de outro e com isso nós quebramos
aquele spect x nós quebramos né aquelas
caricaturas que um grupo jovem de um
local cria em relação ao outro e
exercitar realmente a interculturalidade
exercitar realmente a educação
inter-étnica fundamental para é
exercitar uma nova cidadania e seja
capaz de viver em cidades gigantes na e
seja capaz de vender a
multiculturalidade que agora está toda
aqui diante de mim esse é o significado
da cidade gigantes todas as aldeias
agora estamos morando aqui todas as
culturas como então fazer com que todas
elas contribuam para a sustentabilidade
a sustentabilidade urbana portanto
precisa de uma nova educação uma
educação baseada na ética ou na ética da
terra para enfrentar os grandes desafios
das mudanças climáticas eo gigantismo
pano
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]